bon nicholl nicholl nicholl c'est fini
je peux donc nicole je peux je peux
parler je peux parler jeu je peux je
peux parler alors qu'est ce que tu veux
que je te dise je crois que
tu as tout dit et que tout est dit et
que on s'est tous dit et que partant de
là on n'a plus rien à se dire
surtout après tout ce qu'on vient de se
dire - ya comme une dernière chose que
je voudrais te dire c'est que tu prends
ta valise est eu foule quand tu as
compris tu prends l'ascenseur le pouvoir
à gauche et quand tu es dans la rue tu
prends un taxi tu mets tous adorent tu
foule pense je te quitte
d'ailleurs c'est pour ça qu'on aurait dû
commencer ce qu'ils étaient avant de se
connaître
seulement je te connaissais pas les
pavés la partie facile à n'ont pas de
gestes inutiles a le temps pris c'est
fini ça suffit comme ça un très un point
fini comment le point sur le yaoi c'est
très drôle oui c'est bien le moment de
faire de l'humour après après la victime
a fait mener alors maintenant tu
embarques tour et tu dégages sera
compris tant pick up et à raquettes de
tennis tout ça tu regardes ça allait
circulation et le pic est possible aussi
aller tout ça et la raquette vas-y la
raquette le pick up et la raquette
allez vas-y
et n'oublie pas la raquette tiens les
photographies aussi tu ne donneras à
jérôme ce nain
quoi oui il m'a peut-être foutu 6-0 au
tennis mais c'est 1 1 quand même et puis
si on l'avait pas mis un filet d'une
pompe ça serait peut-être passer
autrement
allez allez circulation et puis on passe
en oublie pas non plus tu as librairie
diététique la régime pour 6 régime pour
ça est ceci et cela alors que s'il y en
avait un ici qui devait faire le régime
c'était moi oui bon à leur écoute
alors là tu reprends ta valise laporte
l'ascenseur le couloir la rue le taxi et
tu dégages voilà allez circulation ciao
bye bye sayonara
l'école c'est fini allez vas tu nicole
attend attend une dernière chose que je
devrais te dire c'est que tu ne
retrouveras jamais un type comme moi à
ta espère bien bon alors
bon alors écoute alors là tu prends ta
valise et bon tu te débrouilles tout
seul je t'indique mais plus chemin à
lyon
allez va moi j'essaye qu'on se quitte
bons amis intelligemment que même s'il
n'y a plus d'amour entre nous il reste
au moins un pionnier un peu d'amitié
1 et toi tu m'insultes alors maintenant
tu tombes à aller dehors
quoi comment le poisson quel poisson à
le poisson rouge
théodore et ben théodore il est très
bien ici dans son bocal 1 il est même
tellement bien qui va rester ici
voilà je le garde théodore reste ici
quoi c'est pas juste
ah oui c'est la mère qui a la garde du
poisson rouge peut-être et ben justement
théodore n'est plus un enfant c'est un
adulte
alors monsieur si je serais très très
bien mon l'occuper comment mais c'est
une pincée de une demi pain c'est de
commencer enfin bon tout les tous les
matins tous les soirs oui et puis
changer l'eau tous les
oui enfin bon je me débrouillerai t
andorre reste ici et toi aussi
et toi aussi bon ben alors seulement une
journée 1
mais qu'on soit bien d'accord si tu
restes c'est uniquement pour t'occuper
du poisson deux jours mais pas plus de
trois jours alors bon ben alors euh tu
renvoies ton taxi tu reviens sur tes pas
tu prend le couloir à droite l'ascenseur
tu sors et là la porte sera ouverte tu
rentres et tu la fermes
non je parle de la porte
écoute ça va pas recommencer non